point number two in your list of ten
here is
uh the impact of the pandemic on the
dating scene and how most men got
screwed
you're you're in california uh like the
most locked down state in the us from
what i understood but
yeah just expand on that for these guys
too
yeah i mean um what wound up happening
was
uh with the lockdowns coming at the
pandemic the social space definitely
was radically altered where guys were
you had literally
no choice but to go online because if
you happen to be out and you're trying
to meet somebody while trying to talk to
the
mask it was a very psychologically
speaking right people were
in very much the stranger danger don't
get me sick mentality so
it just completely killed the in-person
social dynamics
at least for the first three months then
people started to get a little bit more
used to
things get a little bit more adjusted
and some people just got kind of bored
and sick and tired uh
but i do remember you guys had a rule
zero and
john from modern life dating um this was
like back in early march when he was
talking about
yeah we're going into this uh kind of
lockdown era he's like watch what's
gonna happen
online platforms are gonna explode and
it's going to be a very unique
opportunity
and so that was something i definitely
took to heart um
in in my own experimenting and also with
a lot of clients i was working with
saying like hey guys understand
there's gonna be a very unique
opportunity here where literally
everyone from you know your average girl
next door to
your top tier instagram models they're
all gonna be forced to
to be online so if they want to find
some type of social interaction
or have any type of romantic interaction
this is where it's going to be taking
place
so you got to get ready get prepared
because if you're able to adapt
you will be able to absolutely crush it
but if you aren't able to adapt
you're going to be in for a very very
very long
celibate time uh because you're really
everyone's been forced into this one
funnel
and the thing about the online dating
space is that it's definitely
heavily heavily skewed in the girl's
favor and i wrote an
article about this a while ago about how
by design a lot of apps and dating sites
will psychologically blue pill you uh
because of the way that they're set up
and structured
and the biggest thing that they do is
especially for guys is
they give you the scarcity mentality
because you're you know swiping swiping
swiping swiping and you're getting
nothing
and then suddenly you get like one
person that matches with you out of 100
swipes
and you're like oh my gosh like this is
really awesome and well this is the one
person out of 100 i tried swiping on so
i like have to focus in on this one
person so
that kind of reinforces a little bit of
that you would think that would give you
an abundance mentality but for a lot of
guys when they go on there
it actually does the inverse and gives
them um a scarcity and mentality mindset
so it's one of those like you have to
understand the nature of the field that
you're going in
understand how it's stacked against you
and then when you navigate that field
you'll be able to actually do very well
for yourself
by figuring out that pro hacking that
personal science for you
and understanding how what formulas work
to maximize your personal success
one thing i want to mention um to the
point of this pandemic and the impact
it's had on the dating scene
i've i've heard a lot of guys doing
what are being coined as
zoom dates or face time dates like like
that is not a [ __ ] date okay
um if you can't get her to meet you
somewhere
like grab a coffee and go for a stroll
or come over to your place or
to get together face to face you're
failing
like you're like you're really sucking
at this game
um do not settle for a
hour and a half long face time day we
have this radio shear
radio show here in toronto um
and they have this segment called
ghosting and um
you know i hear it every once in a while
when i'm doing some driving in the
morning hours but
there's there's always some story of
some chick that's like
you know i don't know what happened you
know i you know we had a great first
date and they're like well what'd you do
well you know i was walking around the
block and i was showing him around on
facetime and
you know the neighborhood all the sort
and i don't understand why he ghosted me
sort of
it's like hi hello the whole point of a
date is face-to-face
interaction do not fall for any of this
like beta ties
feminized notions that you should just
like hide in your holes
and your purge holes with your masks on
and your bubble suits on
and and date that that's not dating get
face to face if you're too much of a
chicken to do that then don't date
forget about these face time dates
you're wasting your time
i would say if you're a red pill zoom
dates should be against your religion
and vietnamese against it um just it's
something very interesting about the
zoom
date in that particular format and in
general it's just
it's very platonic and it's hard for me
to put exactly my finger on it but
it's it's very very difficult to foster
that attraction
what i've actually found and recommended
to a lot of clients is
skip the zoom date do an actual phone
date like
conversation that actually works out
this is what you're
this is what your typical dude looks
like on a zoom date to a chick
don't don't be one of these dorks
honestly yeah honestly
an old school phone call works so much
better than an actual zoom date
let me uh grab a couple of these super
chats before we go to number three uh
you